hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the vital role a
transformative diagnostics and
optimizing antimicrobial stewardship i'm
robert axl honest of leverage and i'll
be a moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by teaching biosystems t2
Biosystems is focused on developing
innovative diagnostics products to
improve patient health with to FDA's
clear products targeting sectors and a
range of additional products in
development t2 Biosystems is an emerging
leader in the field of invitro
diagnostics for more information please
visit t2 Biosystems com well have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and may encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green two and a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon and the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window as if any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation we
know or some submit your problems
there's a green Q&A button at the lower
left this is an educational webinar and
this offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the C button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process of obtaining your
credit unless introduce today's speaker
dr. michael fowler dr. Fowler is an
accomplished physician educator and
researchers in the area's antifungal
agents and resistance epidemiology of
bacterial and fungal infections and the
role of clinical microbiology laboratory
and hospital infection control he is a
co-editor in chief of the 11th edition
of ASM manual of clinical microbiology
and co-author of medical microbiology
seventh edition and has offered 700
articles in peer-reviewed journals dr.
Fowler currently serves as
chief medical officer I teaching
biosystems I'm now turn it over to the
doctor for his presentation thank you
and welcome it's a pleasure to be able
to provide this webinar and we'll just
proceed on with the next slide so the
outline of the presentation is listed
here we'll first go over briefly
antimicrobial stewardship then discuss
rapid diagnostic for candidemia and
candidiasis and associated antimicrobial
resistance issues we will then discuss
t2m are the technology platform for
rapid detection of sepsis causing
pathogens provide you some case studies
of t2 candida performance in clinical
laboratories to date and then discuss an
upcoming addition to our portfolio which
we teach you bacteria and t2 resistance
so first antimicrobial stewardship you
all are familiar with the concept that
early effective treatment improves
outcomes in people individuals that are
suffering from sepsis specifically
mortality increases by seven point six
percent every hour of delay in
administering appropriate therapy and
you can see in the graph with the blue
bars going down that's a survival
fraction and the gray bars going up
that's time from the onset of
hypotension or clinical sepsis and of
course we'd like to be at the far
left-hand side where we maximize
survival and minimize the time to
appropriate treatment
in microbial stewardship has several
basic principles and the most important
is to optimize the use of antimicrobial
agents to achieve the best clinical
outcomes while minimizing adverse events
and limiting selective pressure that
drive the emergence of resistance
hopefully by that we can reduce
excessive costs attributable to the
suboptimal antimicrobial use these basic
principles are shared by both antifungal
and antimicrobial stewardship programs
and certainly are the part and parcel of
already established stewardship programs
throughout the country and indeed the
world this is a 9 step of document
that's created by munoz that at all of
published last year and it really I
think provides a very good template for
what to consider in antimicrobial
stewardship and specifically this one's
designed for antifungal stewardship
first of all well you create a
collaborative group on mycosis and
antifungal treatment so you have a group
with common interests and expertise
secondly then conducting an audit in
your institution and identify primary
prescribers of antimicrobial therapies
you then want to establish an
educational program on Fitz's diagnosis
and antimicrobial management to assess
knowledge gaps following that
established local guidelines clinical
flowcharts order forms and bundles now
certainly there are many of these that
are published but it's imperative that
each institution customize these to
their own practices and their own
clinicians set up a daily pharmacy alert
for any new antimicrobial prescribed
obviously the pharmacy is a key
component of any stewardship effort and
really is the center for administering
these agents so
they are clearly the ones to be alerted
first implementing rapid diagnostic
testing is increasingly a component of
antimicrobial stewardship and although
we're just beginning to see some of
these being introduced the effectiveness
of such rapid diagnostic testing in
guiding antimicrobial stewardship is a
very attractive component we'd like to
establish bedside interventions both for
diagnostic and therapy face-to-face
interactions are clearly preferable to
other forms of interaction and you
obviously must measure the effectiveness
of your interventions doing predefined
indicators and provide feedback to
clinicians both physicians and nurses to
improve stewardship effective
stewardship of course requires a
multidisciplinary approach certainly
infectious diseases and a pharmacy
especially in ID pharmacists as well as
clinical microbiology are key components
here but other clinicians in terms of
hospital epidemiology critical care
surgery and hospitalists are very
important as is information technology
and of course hospital administration
must support these efforts and must be
adequately informed about the program
and the advantages of there are key
elements that I think antimicrobial
stewardship must address and I think of
these right now also for antifungals as
well as antibacterials we have
diagnostic challenges and we have to
identify high-risk patients and this can
be quite difficult especially trying to
identify the subset at highest risk this
is because we use old slow and less
sensitive testing methods as well
there's a lot of inappropriate
antimicrobial use out there and that's
of course is why we have these
programs the delay and initiating
appropriate therapy is one that we will
specifically address here but also using
the wrong drug when you have resistant
species present in your institution the
wrong dose and this is often the case
with anti-infectives that are under
dosed obviously if you undergo something
you cut the efficacy considerably and if
you overdose of course you have
toxicities the wrong duration either too
short or too long and unfortunately find
in patients that really shouldn't be on
a lot of therapy they're on therapy far
too long we generally don't truncate
therapy too much for those with
documented infections but these are all
part of the program to ensure that
anti-infectives are used appropriately
therapeutic combinations is an issue
that I think everyone deals with and the
fact of the matter is there are very few
therapeutic combinations that have
actually been shown to be of advantage
certainly in patients that are septic
and you have potential for a
multiplicity of different organisms
therapeutic combinations are used quite
a bit but being able to de-escalate and
trim those combinations down to a single
effective agent is again another
objective for antimicrobial stewardship
and then treating the wrong patient
certainly we have a lot of evidence that
patients that are colonized get this
diagnosis being potentially infected and
that colonization is erroneously treated
and that should clearly be avoided
likewise administering prophylaxis
outside of any type of protocol iced
effort in patient populations where
prophylaxis has been documented to be
efficacious is important we do all these
things to control antimicrobial use in
order to maintain the best standard of
care and to control increasing costs as
well as
resistance the many challenges that are
faced by antimicrobial stewardship
programs and first and foremost is
support from administration you need to
get administration on board because
funding for these programs will have to
come from the administration and there's
it's a very complex analysis that I
think shouldn't be taken as too lightly
and early on administration needs to be
brought into this process there's
resistant to change or adoption of
certain practices that haven't been
engrained in the clinical faculty and
that has to be overcome again most
promising Lee with a clinical champion
to help those efforts inadequate
staffing and funding goes right back to
administration and unfortunately we see
too many and I'm microbial stewardship
programs that are understaffed and so
they might fulfill the letter of the law
but they're not nearly staffed well
enough to be as effective as they might
we have to be cognizant of regulatory
requirements such as CMS funding in
administering these programs and the
primary focus on antimicrobial
stewardship has to be first on
antibiotics and then there also has to
be consideration for antifungal
stewardship talk now about rapid
diagnosis for candidemia and candidiasis
the genus Candida contains over 200
species but most of them have not been
identified as human pathogens there are
five species that account for
approximately ninety-seven percent of
human infections worldwide they're
listed in the pie chart to the right
into the albicans followed by candida
glabrata candida perhaps a low subpoena
tropicalis and crew Zi the exact
distribution may vary by
geographic location and risk for example
in in many countries in Europe Canada
perhaps the low system is the second
most common species whereas candida
glabrata is certainly in North America
and other countries such as Denmark the
exact distribution the risk groups also
are important in this regard so you see
candida glabrata and candida crusie I in
stem cell transplant patients who
routinely receive an azole antifungal
agent for prophylaxis during periods of
neutropenia we see candida parapsilosis
and patients on total parenteral
nutrition and in neonates and it's an
important cause of central
line-associated bloodstream infection an
isolation of Candida perhaps villosus
from blood should raise a red flag for
breaks in catheter care we see candida
glabrata most prominently in older
individuals not Indian eights it to any
great extent but certainly in the older
patient population and candida
tropicalis has long been a major
pathogen in oncology patients why do we
need to identify Candida to the species
level well in vitro patterns of
antifungal susceptibility vary
considerably among the different Candida
species to the right we have the listing
of species across the top we have
amphotericin b fluconazole itraconazole
voriconazole new kind of canons as
examples of widely used and often tested
antifungal agents we use the species
identification as a surrogate for
antifungal susceptibility testing for
selecting empirical therapy in many
instances because it takes quite a while
to do the combined ID and susceptibility
testing and you can predict by the
species in many instances
Candida albicans and candida tropicalis
as you see on the right are susceptible
to virtually all classes of antifungal
agents with rare exceptions likewise
Candida perhaps losses there's a
question mark by II kind of tandon's
because at least initially it was
considered that that might not be the
best approach to treat perhaps the
Llosa's because the mi seas are higher
but clearly these the species and the
subspecies in the perhaps celosa complex
do respond quite well clinically to the
aconnick and ins this leaves us with
candida glabrata and candida cruzi i as
the important multidrug-resistant
species that one might encounter
clinically canada cruisy I is well known
for being intrinsically resistant to
fluconazole but it is susceptible to
other aids alls like voriconazole pazza
connors alanis avocados all agents not
listed there cruzi I end labrada are not
optimally susceptible to amphotericin B
they aren't rapidly killed by an tha's
Harrison D and resistant strains have
been detected candida glabrata is less
susceptible to fluconazole then candida
albicans tropicalis or perhaps Llosa's
we see there sdd that susceptible
dose-dependent means that a higher than
normal dose of fluconazole needs to be
used if you're going to use some
Khanna's all to treat candida glabrata
but if candida glabrata is resistant to
fluconazole it will be resistant to all
other azle including itraconazole for
econ us all pause Akana vilanis a Viacom
is all this brings us to the aconnick
and ins which generally are quite active
against all of the common species of
Candida we have a concern with candida
glabrata as it is the one species that
have been shown to rapidly be able to
become resist
Chewie kind of Camden's while being
treated within the kind of canned and so
one needs to keep this in mind and
certainly you should know both the
frequency of candida glabrata in your
institution and its susceptibility to
the clinic and ins species-specific
interpretive criteria for antifungal
susceptibility testing are provided by
the clsi clinical laboratory standard
institute they have clinical break
points as well as epidemiological cutoff
values for those organisms and drugs for
which there are no clinical break points
if we look at commercially available non
culture based diagnostic tests for
candidemia there are relatively few
certainly in the United States we're
left with beta D glucan and t2 Candida
in Europe they have an antigen based
test the main an anti man n test as well
as at least three platforms that utilize
pcr and various detection methods sfc
test erotica and septa fast systems what
you see here is the limit of detection
in terms of colony forming units per
milliliter for those molecular platforms
and you can see that the step c casa
hritik a-- except too fast platforms all
have limits of detection that are well
over ten cfu per mil and many times even
higher the t2 canada has a limit of
detection of 123 cfu per mil limited
detection in this case means the
concentration of organisms in the
material tested that can be detected by
the test at least ninety-five percent of
the time next column shows sensitivity
and you see sensitivities for beta
glucan and then an anti manin in the 75
to 80 three-percent range
both sexy test except the fast fall even
lower than those two antigen based tests
Anna riddick a-- has published
sensitivity of eighty-one percent for
detection of candida in blood TQ candida
by virtue of a clinical trial performed
in 2015 i have a sensitivity of
ninety-one percent the specificity
varies likewise although the all of the
systems except 42 candida have a
specificity that's well below ninety
percent TQ candida my virtue of over
1,500 hospitalized several patients
documented to not the in technical
candid as a specificity of ninety nine
percent you look a turnaround time in
the way i've turned around times rate
ranging from three hours forty-two
candid is it 24 hours or more for other
some of the other platforms ideally
physicians would like to have a rapid
test within four hours through to really
be able to alter their clinical behavior
the test that we have listed here then
for the molecular tests they're all
siiii marked only T to Candida is FDA
cleared as well antimicrobial resistance
we've discussed the different resistance
profiles that you might see with the
common candida species in the
surveillance efforts that my laboratory
has done over the years there are some
certainly concerning emerging resistance
issues candida glabrata leads the list
a's all resistance is at least ten to
twenty five percent of all isolates and
this remains the greatest concern
clinically given the widespread views of
fluconazole and
I zones remember I said candid labrada
if resistant to one is all is resistant
to all of the easels he kind of candids
between three and ten percent of all
isolates of Candida cavada now worldwide
are resistant to the aconnick and ins
and there's a's all in a kind of canned
& Co resistance that can occur in 11 to
fifty eight percent of a's all resistant
isolates and I'll show you some detail
in a minute Canada Pratt celosa as we
said has elevated mi seas intrinsically
to the aconnick and ins and although
clinical response has been relatively
favorable Candida Pressel OSIS is one
species that has been repeatedly found
to have be involved in breakthrough
candidemia and patients on a kind
candids with hazel is only about four
percent of acquired resistance but that
can increase considerably with four long
days all exposure their recent reports
of forty to sixty percent fluconazole
resistance among candida perhaps elusive
bloodstream isolates in california and
in South Africa just to name a couple of
scenarios candida tropicalis in the
united states is generally very
susceptible to fluconazole and other
Azoff but fluconazole resistance is
prominent in countries like Japan and
India where forty percent of candida
tropicalis eye slits have been shown to
be fluconazole resistance resistance of
fluconazole is increasing in other parts
of the world it's about four to seven
percent in Europe that's less than two
percent in the United States but it kind
of can and resistances in the US has
recently emerged and is about two
percent in our surveillance isolates so
these are organisms that should be of
concern to everyone and maybe in your
own institution you have
another that could be of concern to you
exposure to antifungal agents matter we
know that exposure to fluconazole
selects or candidate perhaps our
candidate labrada and candida cruzi i
likewise exposure to kainic and ins
really puts folks at risk for infection
with a kind of kin or resistance in
candida glabrata there are four studies
listed here a sizeable number of
bloodstream isolates of candida glabrata
and the percentage ina can or resistance
ranges from 818 percent that is a figure
that almost precludes the use of Anna
kinda kanden for empirical coverage of
candida glabrata without susceptibility
test certainly if patients have been on
in a kind of kanden prior to documented
infection that is a risk factor for a
kind of canned and resistance in all
four of these studies prior exposure to
in a kind of kanden it has been found to
be an independent risk factor for a kind
of canned and resistant candida glabrata
risk factors for treatment failure are a
kind of canned and resistance in all of
these studies as well and the beta study
prior exposure was well as a
gastrointestinal disorder was probably a
surrogate for a kind of kin and
resistance but certainly the data shows
prior exposure selects for the kind of
cannon resistance the kind of cannon
resistance predicts a poor outcome
I mentioned multi-drug resistance in
bloodstream isolates of kin of abroad on
these are five studies from the United
States or in recent years which show
multidrug resistance between 14 between
11 and fifty-eight percent of
fluconazole resistant candid labrada
isolates so some would consider candid
labrada to be always resistant in our
non susceptible of fluconazole and so
these kinds of figures are a grave
concern especially since we have few
other options besides an amphoteric
sandy product to treat these multi
drug-resistant infections so to
summarize resistance for Candida the
greatest concern is still a Zahl
resistant kantors abroad the potential
for emergence of non albicans species
with inherent or acquired AIDS all
resistance is always there of course
selection for sand Candida cruisy i but
also can def tropicalis and can depress
hosts are clearly known to become a
Zoras istant in certain settings most
canada remain highly susceptible they're
kind of cannons but emergence of
acquired and intrinsic resistance is a
concern for the species that are listed
there it's important to note that azle
on a kind of canada resistance in
candida glabrata does not necessarily
come at a fitness cost and folks I
mentioned this because folks often
connote acquired resistance with
decreased fitness and therefore a less
burial and are less serious pathogen and
that's not the case with candida
glabrata by any stretch non culture
based diagnostics are especially
important in candidiasis overall and
Candida infections range from mucosal
infections to deep-seated infection the
serious infections are candidemia and
deep-seated candidiasis so deep-seated
candidiasis
is an infectious process that results in
or originates from abscesses or other
sites of infection other than the
bloodstream that may cede the
bloodstream or cause local destruction
without ever having a peripheral fun
genea and this figure from a papal by
Clancy and wind and clinical infectious
diseases shows how these overlaps or you
can have candidemia without deep-seated
candidiasis where blood cultures are
positive and you don't necessarily have
feeding of deep tissues or anything and
this is often catheter-related and can
be treated like well on detection with
removal of the catheter and
administration of appropriate antifungal
agents in some scenarios though you may
have candidemia with deep-seated
candidiasis this could be the result of
catheter-related infections that then
feeds end organs such as the kidney the
heart the brain the liver of the spleen
etc or it could be by virtue of Candida
leaching from the gut establishing a
localized infection within the abdominal
cavity and then disseminating from there
through the bloodstream and in some
instances you'll have this deep-seated
candidiasis without positive blood
cultures and this is the missing fifty
percent that Clancy and wind has written
about and that most folks suspect we
might be missing but don't really know
the extent of this and this is really
because of the high mortality associated
with invasive candidiasis this is one
clinical entity that we should really
strive to make the diagnosis
blood cultures won't do that the
sensitivity in detecting invasive
candidiasis of blood cultures is poor
then estimated at about thirty eight
percent in a number of different studies
the time deposit if attea blood cultures
and final identification is also an
issue and certainly maybe as long as 48
hours to blood culture positivity and
identification taking another 48 hours
if conventional methods are used much
shorter if either proteomic or molecular
methods are used but blood cultures are
mean at the heart of invasive
candidiasis care guidelines we need that
trusted and flawed culture method to
really help us identify and detect many
organisms that we wouldn't have
suspected otherwise we have rapid
culture independent diagnostic tests as
I mentioned before that could complement
blood culture and the importance of
rapid diagnostic tests is that they
provide time critical information that
is essential to limit the mortality and
the emergence of antifungal resistance
here's some data 42 Candida this is from
a paper that we published last year in
which this is subsequent to the clinical
trial so we were able to add additional
cases of candidemia or invasive
candidiasis as you can see in the in the
table below so we have 33 total
candidemia cases t to candida being
positive and 31 blood culture obviously
all 33 but then in addition there are 22
other cases of invasive candidiasis 12
of which are proven by deep tissue
biopsy or other invasive means and 10
for which they
be listed as probable or possible
invasive candidiasis and not proven
combining those data together we have a
total of 53 cases detected by t2 Candida
out of 55 total blood culture detecting
only 33 of those 55 for sixty percent so
just from this analysis we have
substantive data that supports the
concerns of Clancy and wind that blood
culture mrs. serious infections due to
Canada g2 Canada has there are other
evidence for detecting invasive
candidiasis when we continue to collect
cases that report the key to Canada is
more sensitive for deep-seated
candidiasis and blood culture in the
clinical trial my first author Milan
aqus published in CID in 2015 there's
one case of intra-abdominal candidiasis
which was detected by t2 missed by 12
consecutive negative blood cultures and
was proven to be a candida albicans
pancreatic abscess upon laparotomy I've
already mentioned the 12 cases of proven
invasive candidiasis and 10 of probable
or suspected invasive candidiasis that
was published in the future microbiology
paper and then some case reports from
henry ford hospital healthcare system in
detroit presented this year or in 2016
sorry two cases of empyema where T to
Canda was the was positive but blood
culture was missed one was polyphen
Genia in a cancer patient that was
correctly identified by t2 candida and
culture from the infected site that is
the chest cavity but blood culture only
identified one species
another patient where candida infection
was missed by blood culture but
identified by t2 Candida causing therapy
to initiate the initiated and
radiography identified abscesses and
showed T to remain positive over weeks
with persistent infected abscesses a
blood culture was negative in that
patient obviously correlating to the
need to control the source of the
infection and then there's lemon tea to
positive blood culture negative but
culture positive from other non blood
specimens many of these have not been
fully investigated for invasive disease
but certainly that's the kind of data
that were collecting and following so T
TMR is the technology that we use and
will now discuss this technology and its
rapid detection of stress is causing
pathogens so t to mr uses magnetic
resonance and it's an innovative
technology with broad applications that
provide species specific results
directly from whole blood without the
need for blood culture sorry cultures
missed from that ring and it provides
those results in an average of four
point three hours and again with a
sensitivity that is well over ninety
percent and highly specific the
published data demonstrates greater than
ninety percent detection compared to
fifty percent from blood culture this
impacts patients is now the t two
platforms now in use at over a hundred
and fifty hospitals in the United States
and Europe there's a proven return on
investment their individual customer
presentations show greater than five
times return on investment and as we'll
discuss in a minute we have a product
pipeline that includes not only the t to
candida panel
the t2 bacteria panel and t2 resistance
panel importantly t2 mr supports
healthcare initiatives that are opposed
by CMS so we have in blue both on the
left hand side of the slide as well as
in the pie chart hospital-acquired
conditions reduction program so
specifically central line-associated
bloodstream infections we have data that
we're t2 has been used to help manage
these infections both to detect them or
to discount the central line as being
the source of infection we have outcome
measures rapid species identification
and early appropriate therapy that
contribute to improved outcomes and then
the hospital readmission reduction
program were you by identifying septic
patients before hospital discharge will
contribute to a lower readmission rate
notably a paper that's impressed in JAMA
right now as shown that sepsis is the
leading cause of hospital readmission
and the most expensive cause of hospital
readmission and finally Medicare
spending per beneficiary we hope to be
able to impact here because
misdiagnosing patients negatively
impacts efficiency and cost reduction
measures and we note that with all of
this taken into account and 2017 the
maximum amount of reimbursement that CMS
will withhold for these measures is
three percent so t2 mr provide faster
more accurate detection assesses causing
pathogens I think I've shown you some of
that data so if you look at this time
line you see T to Candida result
positive or negative and 4.3 hours on
average between five and ten hours you
can ensure the patients on the right
drug either if they're negative no drug
for an antifungal or
if they're Candida albicans for example
fluconazole would be a reasonable step
down drug with routine blood culture you
see in zero hours you have symptoms
present you take the blood culture
samples 24 hours some blood cultures
that may be positive the average time
however is about 48 hours once positive
you can have a up to 120 hours where the
blood culture results are completed and
since best species identification has
been assigned shorter times with maldi
or other molecular platforms and
certainly 120 hours for negative blood
culture results of you reported and
there for 27 hours 27 days for the
patient to get on the right drug or get
off the long drug so in this cartoon you
see on the left hand side photos of the
cartridge the cartridge being assembled
placed into the instrument and press go
that's as simple as it gets blood is
drawn the tube is placed on the
cartridge the cartridge into the T 2 DX
instrument 4.3 hours you get
species-specific results which enable
targeted therapy as opposed to blood
culture where large amounts of blood
need to be drawn incubating for 125 days
and then between 1 and 48 hours for
species identification on positive blood
cultures remember a rapid identification
methods that we have and use in the lab
nowadays still require positive cultures
so this is a multi-stage slide that will
look to show the potential key to
candida and t2 bacteria impact this is
no culture required approach that gives
you passage and identification in a
rapid timeframe in the figures to be
seen you have in green perceived
benefits and below that in orange or
grey the other effect so when you have a
patient that has a blood culture drawn
if a t2 is drawn empiric therapy has
started that's where you start if it's
positive t 2 is positive you have faster
detection of bacterial fungal pathogens
and it can help physicians adjust the
initial treatment earlier it also gives
you an identification of the fungal or
bacterial pathogen and one may influence
therapy by adding or subtracting agents
that have been part of the empirical
treatment paradigm if t2 is negative
higher sensitivity of the t2 result will
result in fewer false negatives negative
predictive value in most scenarios would
be well over ninety nine percent
allowing more patients to receive
appropriate rather than inappropriate
treatment so you can adjust treatment
empirical treatment as need be the
escalation is important and could be
facilitated by t2 results or patients
requiring further judge adjustment
initial treatment pathogen
identification and possibly narrowing
treatment so for example if one follows
the IDSA guidelines and starts out
empirically within a kind of kanden if
you detect candida albicans one then
knows that you can deescalate safely
once the base
and stable according to the guidelines
with some cana zone and then
susceptibility testing could further
streamline those results if the patient
receives the correct treatment earlier
only those require further adjustment or
C's susceptibility testing and then
treat to resolution finally
discontinuing empirical antibiotics or
antifungal agents can be facilitated by
ATT result as well we're movin
unnecessary antibiotics for patients
without sepsis to help save on treatment
costs and prevent unnecessary side
effects so now will present some case
studies these have been on this slide
have been presented a tidy week this
past year from Henry Ford at that time
they attest with 142 patients they found
reduced median time to identification
from previous years down from forty 1.75
hours to 25.25 hours so key to testing
or do some time to identification by 16
and a half hours reduced median times
active therapy historically 39.6 hours
to active therapy versus 26.6 hours OT
to testing reduced time to active
therapy by 13 hours certainly
significant when you have a critically
ill patient and the median I see you
like to stay in days was decreased by
seven days Andrey Ford cost savings of
an estimated annualized 2.3 million
dollars based on the savings in terms of
optimizing treatment of infected
patients
importantly the all cause mortality in
the t2 Candida cohort was slightly
higher 39 verse thirty-three percent in
the study but this is not statistically
significant and may have some issues
with the calculation this demonstrates
key factors for test evaluation as well
in the poster in in the presentation the
investigators really emphasized the
importance of pairing the drawing of t2
with a blood culture or concerning the
timing of anti-fungal administration so
that you can really critically evaluate
the performance of this technology in
your own scenario and the rapid
turnaround time the good neck negative
predictive value of T 2 should support
future antimicrobial stewardship efforts
additional presentations that I week ID
we come from two other hospitals
Riverside Hospital in Huntsville hostel
Riverside in California huntsville in
alabama riverside at 59 patients 642
candida positive three of them had
positive blood cultures and they have 53
t2 candid and negative patients none of
them that positive blood cultures there
are eight of those 53 negative patients
that were on antifungal therapy and that
was discontinued based on the TT result
and the clinical status in those eight
nations of the patients with positive ki
to results prior to their pot positive
test results none were being treated for
candidemia and candidemia or antifungal
therapy was then administered five of
those six patients within six hours of
testing and a hundred percent within
nine hours so and the average the
results were available in the hospital
reporting system an average is six point
three hours so clearly early detection
identification of fungal infections
resulted in focus on the appropriate
antifungal therapy in huntsville testing
hundred and sixty 260 TV Canada panel
results 14 Umbra positive nine with
positive blood cultures 146 were
negative none of them had positive blood
cultures the potential of blood culture
missed sixty-four percent of patients
with candidemia invasive candidiasis the
average duration of antifungal therapy
in terms of days of therapy for patients
with a negative T 2 result with four
days in the average time that the
escalation was forty two point six hours
so physicians can certainly de-escalate
and stop therapy in the face of a
negative result reduction in days of
therapy and time to be escalation
equated to an estimated two hundred
eighty dollars saved per patient and the
investigators concluded that the t2
canned of the panel demonstrated greater
sensitivity compared to blood culture
that is that candidemia at their
facility provided a much faster time to
antifungal treatment modification one of
our very first sites to report their
experiences Lee Memorial Hospital system
in Fort Myers Florida this is their
first 182 patients tested seven had
positive teach you can to the results a
time to appropriate antifungal therapy
compared with the period preeti to
Candida was a reduction of 34 hours it
was 40 hours preeti to canada six hours
post t to candida antifungal therapy was
reduced in a number of patients with
negative results it was avoided entirely
in 74 patients it was discontinued after
one dose in 27 patients
a length of stay was 13 days in the post
T to test cohort versus 20 days in
candid Enoch patients in the pre key to
group they estimate a net antifungal
savings of a hundred and ninety five
dollars for every patient tested now
we're going to mention t2 bacteria and
t2 resistance the teacher bacterial
panel will include the following
pathogens largely derived from the
escape pathogen group staph aureus in
our caucus p.m. klutzy oh and ammonia
pseudomonas aeruginosa afinitor bahmani
and escherichia coli preliminary limit
of detection 125 colony forming units
per milliliter essentially the same
limit of detection f4 t to Candida we
know blood culture detect that premiun
about fifty percent of patients that are
clinically suspected of having sepsis
and so being able to identify these key
pathogens is clearly important the pie
chart on the right shows the
distribution of those organisms
including t2 candidate so you can see
that it encompasses a fair proportion of
the total about sixty percent of the
total organisms that might be expected
in septic patients we know in the pie
chart shown here but about sixty percent
of patients are appropriately treated by
empiric therapy the forty percent or
inappropriately treated and you can see
in the table that the passages that
we're dealing with this is not even
including Canada all have significantly
high mortalities in fact these organisms
as well as candida lead the list in
terms of pathogens that cause mortality
in hospitalized patient
by using both T to bacteria and t2 you
can de that we provide species
identification for about sixty percent
of sepsis cases and in combination with
empiric therapy ensure that ninety-five
percent of patients will be
appropriately treated on days 0 our
product pipeline is seen here so we're
not just about Candida on top we see the
fungal stream we have key to Canada
right now we intend to develop key to
Candida further to include pin candida
markers as well as ultimately detection
of F KS mutations for a kind of hand and
resistance or bacterial we have the t2
bacteria panel that's in clinical trials
right now and we anticipate being able
to provide that commercially later this
year we will also then continue to
develop T 2 psi or bloodstream infection
which has panned gram-negative and
gram-positive pan nice and
coagulase-negative staff and will
ultimately develop resistance markers
and we have collaborations with a
pharmaceutical company allergan to
develop t2 carbo which will have
carbapenem ace markers g2g SB L&T to
gram-positive resistance markers so that
we will eventually 28 2018 and Beyond
have broad multiplex 30-plus species and
resistance markers including and
pathogen detection to aid in the fight
against sepsis we also have a line of
investigation and development for
tick-borne panel pathogens so a
partnership with Canon life sciences has
helped us develop the key to Lyme panel
that will be
going to clinical trials in the future
and we also intend to then develop an
extended tick-borne disease panel so to
conclude we hope that antimicrobial
stewardship and rapid Diagnostics will
improve care both increasing awareness
of candidiasis and other serious
infections and prove pathogen detection
focus therapy this should save lives
save dollars and avoid resistant
selection pressure and what that were
finished and thank you for your
attention well thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on a question and answer session
I would like to remind our audience how
to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we're going to
try to answer as many questions as we
possibly can today any questions that
were unable to get to today will be
answered offline via email our first
question for you is you talk a little
bit about your partnerships here can you
talk more about the partnership with
allergen again is very interesting there
are many hurdles to developing effective
new antimicrobial agents and clearly
that is certainly something that
worldwide is being promoted and Allergan
has really taken up the challenge and so
they have a number of agents them and
they're in developing these agents
bringing them to clinical trials there's
a great interest in being able to use a
rapid diagnostic test to identify
patients for enrollment for the clinical
trial within the same day that they're
evaluated currently we evaluate patients
they get cultures and they can't have
been on any other antimicrobial agents
for 48 hours or less and that is a
barrier to entering patients in clinical
trials so by using a rapid diagnostic
test that gives species identification
is one way of streamlining those kinds
of trials by including resistance
markers especially for organisms that
might be targeted by the drug that the
pharmaceutical company has developed
should also be able to facilitate those
clinical trials and indeed may even
improve the efficacy of the
antimicrobial agents by both identifying
the infected patient earlier and getting
the appropriate treatment on board
earlier as well
so we're seeing more and more c orifice
in the united states are there plans to
include that in your panel candid arcs
candida oras candida oras is a recently
identified species of canada that has
now popped up in a number of different
countries and there are a few cases
around 10 or so in the united states a
concern about Candida oras is twofold
one is that it seems to be hyper
transmissible so that a patient infected
or even colonized with canada oras
effectively contaminates the entire room
much in a way that we've come to see
with clustered in difficile or
vancomycin-resistant enterococci and so
the threat for it spreading within a
hospitalized environment is great and
the CDC is very concerned about that and
more so because Candida oras has also
been shown to be able to readily become
multidrug-resistant much like candidate
labrada does so that combination of
hyper transmissibility and antifungal
resistance in a species that does seem
to cause serious infection is a cause
for concern Candida oras cannot be
identified reliably by any of the
methods routinely used in clinical
laboratories right now including both
molecular and proteomic platforms both
of the MALDI top systems do not identify
Canada oras yet unless you have a
research you use only database and there
you may be able to identify it karen
carol has a short paper in the februari
journal of clinical microbiology
that very nicely describes this it can
be identified by DNA sequencing and
that's how it has been done thus far so
it is a difficult organism it is
misidentified and we fully intend to
have that on a future panel we just
don't have it right now in our next
flushing when blood culture is negative
what are you confident that you're
detecting deep-seated candidiasis well
certainly we've done preclinical
evaluations to definitively show the
limit of detection is show that we can
get down to one colony forming unit per
milliliter what we know about Canada and
it actually it is true about bacterial
pathogens as well as that in most
bloodstream infections the concentration
of organisms in blood is well less than
10 colony forming units per milliliter
in fact for most of the targets that
we've discussed today is 50% are less
than one colony forming unit per
milliliter we know that we need to
culture an adequate volume of blood in
order to get at that level of detection
and we need to incubate it for long
enough what is clear is that blood
cultures are not performed uniformly
throughout the world there are delays in
getting them onto instruments there
our under inoculated blood cultures and
too few steps are obtained all of those
will undermine the ability to detect low
numbers of organisms with the cases that
we identified thus far and now we're
well over close to 90 cases that I know
of that are in terms of being evaluated
where we are positive and blood culture
is negative and we have prior blood
culture confirmation or confirmation
from deep seats eep sites like
intra-abdominal abscess these and tissue
biopsies that the t2 result matches that
that other result so we have certainly
looked we look at every case where
there's a discrepancy and we have
ongoing studies to evaluate those and
we're very confident that we can detect
the low concentration of organisms that
are necessary to optimally manage
patients and to not include patients as
false positives our predictive value of
a negative is very high and depending on
the prevalence in the population or
predicted value of a positive will be
equally high
and with the time given it looks like we
have time for one more question I do
want to remind our audience that any
additional questions will be answered
via email so with this last question
here with Elodie of one cfu per ml how
do you know that you're not too
sensitive well my answer the previous
question also gets to that issue with
all of the pathogens listed on T to
candida and t2 bacteria as I mentioned
there is very good evidence that low
concentrations of organisms are highly
prevalent and we want to be able to
detect those we want to be able to
detect those that because they do have
clinical consequences we know if staph
aureus is in the blood it's causing a
problem we know if Candida is in the
blood it's causing a problem these are
results microbiologically that are not
questioned by clinicians in terms of
being able to act on them and I would
submit that those platforms that don't
get down to one cfu per mil are not
being used when you evaluate the
literature and you discuss things with
colleagues throughout the world they
realize the disadvantages of not being
able to detect down to one cfu per mil
and know that they're missing infected
patients and so can't rely on those
diagnostic platforms so our goal is to
have a platform that we get down to that
clinically significant level and we are
not detecting DNA
amia we don't detect free-floating DNA
we detect intact cells that's where
we're different from any of the
molecular platforms that are out there
for direct detection right now we don't
do DNA extraction so we're not losing
target in the process and we are not
detecting components of an organism that
might be the result of dying organisms
releasing their DNA from the gut and it
getting into the bloodstream our
specificity is our strongest suit right
now and so just from the clinical trial
we have over 1500 hospitalized
uninfected yet febrile patients that
have negative t 2 results and so we have
very good specificity database and we
are always increasing our sensitivity
database to include those patients with
each seated infection or which we are
often missing or mistreating and before
we conclude today dr. give any final
closing remarks remarks our finger marks
sorry certainly we have a very
tremendous opportunity these days or
utilizing new technology to save patient
lives certainly it will save money as
well but the safe patient lies and to
directly attack the worldwide problem of
antimicrobial resistance effectively we
need to have these new technologies used
intelligently
and cost-effectively and certainly from
the perspective of t2 Biosystems we are
working with the community to create
treatment plans care plans diagnostic
plans that will benefit each and every
institution that employs the t2
platforms thank you again doctor for
your time today I also like to thank our
sponsor teaching biosystems for making
today's educational webcasts possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand dealing through May 2017
you'll receive an email from lab words
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
for event announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event and until next time davai